today's bitcoin weekly update is with
will clemente the lead insights analyst
at blockware will and i have a great
conversation we talk about everything
from reflexivity to market sentiment to
a number of various quantitative data
points i really enjoyed this
conversation with will and i hope you
guys enjoy it as well don't forget that
these episodes every saturday morning
are brought to you by ftx ftx got super
cheap fees sometimes as much as 85
cheaper than their competitors go check
out ftx by clicking on the link in the
description now let's get into this
episode with will i hope that you guys
learned quite a bit from will what's up
buddy
yo yo how's it going jess the the young
wizard what's up dude we're super
excited we got a whole bunch of stuff to
talk to before we jump into charts what
is uh what's your general read right now
on kind of market sentiment it feels
like people were real scared uh two
weeks ago or so when all the contagion
was kind of taking its toll now it feels
like people got a little bit more relief
and
might not be as scared is that your
general sense
yeah i mean i would say that you know
perhaps rightfully so some of the fear
that we've seen over the last few weeks
has been the most extreme that i've ever
personally experienced maybe rivaled by
like the coveted crash and i remember
during the cobot crash people were
wondering if like
you know the the fundamental bitcoin
protocol had like broken or something
because i mean we just had gone down
like 50 in a day but i mean it has been
pretty wild i mean every single entity
that appears to have been kind of the
adult in the room turned out to just be
degenerates like the rest of us so
um
yeah i mean i think some of the some of
the fears been you know rightfully
warranted but that doesn't mean you know
i think a lot of the a lot of the
flushing out of mal investment and
leverage that we've
uh seen over the last month or two will
be very healthy for the space long term
and
you know i think a lot of people have
been saying oh well you know this this
hurts the credibility of the asset class
people aren't going to want to touch
this thing with the 10-foot pole because
you know we've got all these you know
ponzinomics in the space and all that
kind of stuff um i mean i think you know
when i've at least spoken to some of
these you know uh traditional finance
entities that you know i don't have a
very large circle of but i would say you
know a handful of these individual
individuals that i've spoken to
uh they seem to you know be more excited
about this than anything because they've
seen this you know happen many times in
the traditional uh landscape i mean for
example like
you know what happened with three ac you
know you've seen that take place in
traditional markets i mean that's not
anything that's unique to
uh to crypto so i think some of these
guys are kind of starting to get excited
about basically buying distressed assets
in a marketplace that's experienced
tremendous amount of for selling and is
in a state of you know tremendous amount
of fear
you've got a lot of you know crypto
native people that are now questioning
even the the viability of of the space
uh perhaps you know not on the magnitude
of what took place in 2018 but certainly
are starting to see some of that
yeah it um it's uh
it's pretty interesting when you start
thinking through how uh a lot of this
balance is out and your reference is
back to 2020 2018 you know in bear
markets before uh
i think a lot about
there's just more eyeballs
like i was trying the other day to
figure out a good way to analyze it
50
of all bitcoin and crypto investors
weren't here for march of 2020 like that
was my general guess right maybe i'm off
plus or minus you know 10 15 percent in
either direction
but like a very large percentage of
people who right now this second hold
a crypto asset were not around in march
of 2020. an even bigger percentage of
them weren't around in 2018 right and
you just kind of go all the way back and
so it's like i don't know take the like
second bear market it was 2013 or
whatever it was right uh
three percent one percent of all people
in the market today were around for that
so it's just like so many people are new
they don't have the context of 2020 or
2018 and so of course the market cycles
to some degree will repeat uh because
those people have to kind of be
indoctrinated into what happens as well
right
sure yeah i mean i think part of why
bitcoin cyclicality is is um so
reflexive is
because it's such a new asset class so
every cycle you know when we run up in
price it's basically like a massive
marketing campaign for btc in the
broader crypto market as well
you get a tremendous amount of new users
because bitcoin just hasn't reached
saturation i mean we did our user
adoption came on here and talked through
that report
uh you know it's a very very small
portion of the world actually you know
has has any ownership of bitcoin or any
other crypto asset uh so you know every
single cycle you get a new amount of um
you know new magnitude of new market
participants and on the move down you
know some of those people get flushed
out and capitulate as you know they come
to the realization that they really have
no fundamental understanding of the
asset that they're holding uh you know
why they're holding it aside from the
fact that the price is going up um and
you know you can see this in in the data
as well when we get back into the bear
market you know some of those
individuals that you know come into uh
into the bowl they stay around although
again a lot of them a lot of them do
leave
but the kind of key takeaway is that
like every bear market that base of
people who stay is higher and higher and
higher uh and you know when you're down
70 to 80 percent an asset you know
especially lately right i mean we've got
again a tremendous into this in a moment
a tremendous amount of force selling
from basically every type of entity that
you could think of in the space um you
know you've got you know the worst macro
environment that i've ever seen in my
short little career in markets and
um you've got all that kind of
uncertainty you know who's buying down
70 80 percent you know these are people
who are likely relatively you know you
have some some traders that are perhaps
looking for like the short-term mean
reversion trade but i would say the vast
majority of it
are likely you know people who are
relatively time insensitive
and are looking to you know accumulate
this this asset at a distressed price um
and so that you know when you're down
80 85 percent at the bottom of every
bitcoin bear market you know the people
that that are buying down there and the
the quote unquote you know uh cohort of
you know hands that that uh the supply
gets concentrated into are those who
aren't going to sell most likely for for
you know a 20 30 percent move
and that's what allows you know these
these moves back to the upside to be
so aggressive um in the same way that
you know the the downside moves are so
aggressive because the people that are
buying you know once the asset is up you
know 10x from the bottom you know these
are people that are you know likely just
going to get shaken out once once number
isn't going up anymore um so these
dynamics really
um
cause you know a bit more momentum and
fuel to the to the typical you know
market cycles that you would see in
bitcoin uh and again you know some of it
as well as is there's been a lack at
least um historically of a way to kind
of tie in bitcoin to a fundamental
valuation i mean i would argue some of
the
entrain related stuff is the best way to
to do so that we have but i do think
that that kind of exacerbates a lot of
the fear and greed around just sole
price action
talk a little bit about reflexivity i've
seen you tweet a number of different
times about that concept and maybe
explain how you think about uh what is
kind of a timeless investing uh idea or
at least one that's been around for a
while now obviously soros and many
others have popularized uh and then why
you're so interested in reflexivity when
you're analyzing you know the bitcoin
crypto market
sure so i've got this
book on my desk right here it's called
the the alchemy of finance by george
soros and i know some people don't like
george soros for some non-financial
related reasons i would say
you know you can pull someone's ideas
out you know even if you disagree with
other aspects of them so i'm gonna you
know not comment on some of those
alternative reasons why people dislike
soros but i do think from a financial
markets perspective he's got a lot of
valuable insight um in the book you know
he he talks about in like the first five
pages he talks about this concept of
reflexivity
kind of from a high level and
the way to kind of think about it is
that price movements and and actions in
the marketplace
reinforce these these beliefs or
behaviors so you know for example
as you know you you think bitcoin is
going to be more widely adopted by you
know corporate uh balance sheets right
and that's something that a lot of us
thought in
late 2020 you know we saw sailor buy-in
uh and then you know after that we saw
tesla add bitcoin to their balance sheet
at the beginning of february 2021. you
know at the time that reinforces that
belief from market participants that
you're going to see continued um adding
of bitcoin to corporate balance sheets
and that that extension of of belief um
in in you know optimism in the market
gets extended because of the actions
that are taking place and it reinforces
and further pushes out the expectations
of of market participants and that you
know that happens conversely
to the downside as well where you know
you have you know uh
bad news events or
um events that that are you know
quite bearish like some of the things
we've been seeing lately uh with some of
these blow-ups from different entities
in the space that reinforce and and
continue to push people's expectations
lower and lower and lower uh and again i
i think a lot of that in the in the
bitcoin in crypto market gets
exacerbated because of kind of the lack
of you know saying okay well you know
bitcoin is at this relative to its you
know free cash flows that it's that's
drawing in um again i do think there's
other ways to value bitcoin aside from
that but i think that you know the
sensitivity to
basing bitcoin's value off of price
action really kind of uh extends out
some of those those effects of the
reflexivity in the marketplace you know
a lot of people were talking about um
you know over the last two to three
years the concept of of you know the
super cycle which i personally never
bought into um but you know it the
reason why
was was really eloquently stated by
light so there's this guy like crypto
he's uh supposedly a prop trader on on
twitter he's anonymous um but i think
he's got a lot of insightful things to
say and he went on a podcast actually at
the pico top of of last year and i was
listening back to it last week and you
know one thing that he said that
basically ties into what's what's stated
by by soros is that you know although an
asset can go through a super cycle and
you know obviously not a whole lot
changes fundamentally with the bitcoin
protocol but the infrastructure around
it does does change evolve and mature uh
but you know the other crypto assets you
know uh you have new you know innovation
whether they need you know whether
they're decentralized or need a token
like that's a whole other discussion i
don't want to get into but like
you know i i would say that the utility
of something like a maker you know maker
dow or uniswap is better than the
garbage that was around in the 2018 ico
craze um so you know you have increasing
utility of the underlying technology and
again the infrastructure around bitcoin
um and you know that can go through a
super cycle but what does not change is
the underlying you know human behavior
and
the kind of psychological dynamic of
fear and greed that drives markets and
you know no matter how strong
the improvement of the underlying
technology can be
that doesn't mean that humans will not
always continue to push out expectations
further than the underlying value is no
matter how strong it is and conversely
to the downside no matter how bad things
get
humans will always push expectations
lower than they actually truly should be
because of kind of that that dynamic
that soros talks about so when you take
that idea and you look back over the
last couple of weeks with all the uh the
contagion the
unsecured lending um you know just all
kind of the chaos and uncertainty there
how do you think through what was like
mechanical in the industry of just like
yes this was very obviously going to
unwind versus what is more um like
psychologically driven or kind of fear
and uncertainty driven where there's
people actually panic selling and uh
doing that and the reason why i ask kind
of backwards looking is i think it's
really hard to understand what's going
to happen in the future but at least if
we
uh do analysis on on the last couple of
weeks what would your
kind of process look like there
yeah i mean the
the fear side is a bit more difficult
because it's not quantitative but like
i mean to start so
you know when we look at what's taken
place with you know all these these
crypto lenders right i mean a lot of
this has been
you know people seeing that okay perhaps
you know maybe this this platform that
i'm using is insolvent or you know they
have some some you know mismatched
assets and liabilities i'm going to pull
my assets off the platform
and so essentially we've seen kind of a
classic you know bank run style
event take place on some of these
platforms um you know and also by the
way that's reflected in in the on-chain
data when we look at like exchange
outflows from centralized platforms
we've seen the strongest amount of
exchange outflows in bitcoin's history
like straight up um and you know whether
you know i think the market's gotten a
bit more nuanced to say whether that has
like direct price related effects um i i
would say that you know i think that's a
reflection of in in recent times just
kind of the hysteria around people
questioning the solvency of any
centralized entity in the crypto space
and is also why you know bitcoiners
advocate to say
not your keys not your coins um so you
know that's one example of perhaps you
know maybe
some of these entities did have you know
bad debt but then on top of that you had
you know users withdrawing their funds
because they became concerned around
a lot of the contagion effects and that
perhaps you know exacerbated uh some
things but i mean look i think again and
now i guess we can get into this stuff
in a bit more granularity but like
there's been a lot of foreselling that's
that's taken place um
you know let's just i guess let's just
start with
uh this one chart so i
i'm not sure if uh
which one uh
jordy has the the uh newsletter let's
look at
core so it's it's the correlation of
bitcoin's market cap and eats market cap
to the crypto market cap um
it's like the third chart down in the
newsletter all right this one shows the
market cap of bitcoin in the market cap
of eth at top and then the uh
correlations kind of going down right
yeah exactly so we're looking at
bitcoin's market cap plus ethereum's
market cap and then we're running a
correlation of that to the crypto market
cap excluding bitcoin and east uh and so
you know as as most people in the in the
space know bitcoin and eth are really
the two most liquid assets um
you know of course there's there's
tether and usdc but you know those
aren't you know uh directional assets um
you know crypto i mean bitcoin and ether
are really the only
two you know liquid crypto assets uh in
this space
and so
what's interesting to me about this
chart is when you see this decline in in
the correlation it's it's pretty strange
uh it's like
probably like the most aggressive
decline in correlation that you've seen
between these two uh in a long time what
what i think this is representing is for
selling uh and the reason is because you
know in an event like this where you
know either you have you know recently
we just you know we just
finished out the the second quarter so
you have not only the end at the end of
the quarter but also the end of the
first half of the year uh and the end of
the month like all three of those things
you know perhaps you have some fund
redemptions taking place
and then you can also have you know some
of these lenders concerned about the
solvency
of all their counterparties so they're
asking them to post collateral just to
you know see if they if they do have the
assets that they're claiming to have you
know all these kinds of things perhaps
are forcing people to
you know trim off holdings in in assets
that you know they they have to uh trim
off not assets that they necessarily
want to trim off um and you know the
only again the only assets that really
have you know liquidity to absorb large
you know large outflows are btc and eth
um you know a lot of these a lot of
these altcoins just really are just
getting all the liquidity in them
dried up so you know even if you want to
exit a position you really can't do so
without you know having a like material
effect on the on the price and then on
top of that let's say you're like a vc
invested in some project from like you
know some seed stage you know you're not
going to really want to
drive the price down 70 percent because
that's just gonna really hurt your
reputation as a vc so i i think a lot of
these things have kind of added up to
seeing this what appears to me as a
dynamic of for selling of the two most
liquid uh assets in the space
so when you start to look at you know
something like this let's then overlay
it with uh murad in his uh uh much
anticipated return to twitter he he uh
started to post uh this uh this graphic
uh or this chart and what he shows is
the bitcoin usd
uh trading pair and then he shows uh the
total amount of uh tether in usdc
and they appear at least visually to be
inversely correlated when bitcoin goes
down it appears that there's more stable
coins there um
is it just that simple like there's an
inver inverse uh
correlation or no
yeah i mean
so what what this chart is essentially
comparing is just the total crypto
market cap to usdt and usdc which are
the two largest stable coins uh and so
kind of the the concept behind this
is that whenever you get to kind of the
upper bound of this like ascending
channel
that means that there's a large amount
of um capital sitting in stables versus
uh being deployed in the crypto market
and then whenever you get to the bottom
end of the channel uh what's what what
that is showing you is that you know
there's a large amount of capital
deployed into
uh actual liquid tokens relative to uh
the amount of you know kind of dry
powder through through stable coins
sitting on the sideline uh and and you
know as you'll see we're kind of around
that that question mark um what murad is
essentially you know kind of
hypothesizing in this in this chart is
that you've got a large amount of assets
sitting in dry powder via via stable
coins relative to being deployed in the
crypto market
uh and you know as you can see sometimes
you know we kind of hang out on that on
that upper bound for you know perhaps a
month or two but
you know generally speaking whenever
you're pushing up against that upper
bound of the channel that's been a good
time to accumulate um and you know part
of you know part of
moves is not necessarily
it's people like being on the sideline
and not you know being in the market and
then forcing them to chase and i i would
say there's a fair amount of people
because of a lot of the uncertainty that
are waiting for the market to show them
strength to get back in um so that's
just something to kind of put this into
context with with you know perhaps as
you know if the market did move up you
would see people you know want to wait
for that confirmation to get back out of
stables but for now
you're seeing a large amount of dry
powder that's kind of sitting on the
sideline relative to
being deployed in the actual market
got it you also uh recently put out uh
some charts around the bitcoin four-year
trend and you identified that that
four-year
trend bitcoin is trading below it for
only the fourth time ever
how important is that like for only four
times in the history of bitcoin sounds
like it's super super important but but
how do you evaluate this
sure i mean when we talked earlier about
you know how do we value bitcoin uh i
would say there's there's two
two real ways to do so
uh one would be looking at kind of the
underlying like fundamental dynamics via
on chain what's going on with miners
those types of things
and the other would be more price and
trend related
so what this is looking at is the latter
so we're looking at the four year price
trend of btc uh we've seen michael
saylor post about this
and then when we look at i i kind of
unselected these other
metrics in the chart but you can also
look at the number of standard
deviations from the four-year trend
that's been kind of a good signal to to
see where bitcoin's peaking out but uh
this four-year trend is historically
served as kind of this
support area uh for bitcoin in bear
markets uh when we look at 2015 uh
excuse me 2018 uh 2020 and and then as
well uh recently we're below it it's
just again the fourth time ever that
we've that we've gone below uh you know
i think the question when we look at a
lot of these metrics uh you know across
the board is you know these are all in
like these deep value levels but the
argument to be made is like is this time
different uh because of kind of the
macro backdrop i don't you know i don't
know you know obviously
you know no one knows time will tell but
uh i i think you know
at least from you know a long-term
investor's perspective it's a good time
to start you know putting some some dry
powder in in the market and you know
starting to average in a bit here uh at
these kind of levels that historically
you know marked bitcoins uh at least you
know an accumulation in bottoming zone
you know another good example is like
looking at the uh the next chart this is
the basically the deviation from the
200-day trend uh and then we also up
there have realized price which is like
the average cost basis of all the
investors in the market bitcoin's only
ever traded below both of those for
three percent of its existence and a lot
of that took place in in that that
portion in 2011 and if you you know
pulled that bit out it would be even
smaller than three percent uh but it's
just another you know way to to
illustrate you know we're at historical
levels of of what appears to be you know
cheap valuation relative historical
valuation
um for bitcoin
i think um one one last i guess dynamic
we could talk about is is the dynamics
with miners that's been something that i
think has been important to to keep in
mind lately
uh and it also kind of ties into a lot
of the force selling uh that that we
talked about has been taking place
so for several weeks now we've been
putting in the newsletter
essentially that
you're seeing favorable conditions for
miners to starting to have to unplug
i tweeted about a month ago that i said
you know lower bitcoin price higher hash
and difficulty and higher energy costs
have put serious pressure on minor
margins hash price is now the lowest
since october of 2020
hash ribbons have crossed and i'll talk
about what all this means hash ribbons
have crossed indicating machines
unplugging and miners sending bitcoin to
exchanges so
what's been taking place is
you have this kind of delayed effect
historically with hash and price so you
know there's a delay in when you order
asics and when you're actually able to
plug them in for a variety of reasons um
but you know if we go back and look you
know the most recent before now was you
know 2017 2018 you saw bitcoin's price
peak at 20k and actual hash rate you
know didn't peak until two three four
months after that uh and what happens is
like miners are essentially the way you
can think of it is their long bitcoin
price short hash rate and thus short
difficulty as well which is a byproduct
of hash rate
uh and so
what happens is like the the price is
going down of bitcoin
while it's becoming increasingly
competitive uh to get the the same minor
revenue
and so what you can look at to
illustrate this is something called hash
price so this compares minor revenue and
bitcoin's price and hash price is at the
lowest that it's been since uh mid to
late 2020 so it's just showing you it's
i think hash price is a good way to kind
of illustrate
the compression of minor margins and
then you throw on that we've got you
know inflation at 40-year highs and a
lot of that has been driven from from
energy costs so you've also got you know
higher higher energy
costs which is miners biggest uh
operational expenditure that they have
uh on top of that so you know all that
puts together kind of the perfect recipe
for
a lot of minor margin compression
and so at the time of posting this like
a month ago you had saw hash ribbons
which are looking at the 30 and 60 day
moving averages of hash rate starting to
cross which had illustrated that you're
starting to see uh some machines getting
unplugged um now we've seen confirmation
of that cross and we've
we've seen the the 30-day cross pretty
significantly below
the 60 day which is showing you that
machines are starting to get unplugged
and then on top of that we've started to
see over the last month especially after
after i posted this
inflows of btc from miners to exchanges
and then kind of the the cherry on top
was over the last few days uh we saw
core scientific selling off 7202 btc
at an average price of 23k which comes
out to about 167 million dollars that
they had to liquidate and so you know
the the dynamics that we're seeing here
with miners have taken place before uh
you know you had nick carter on about a
month ago and he talked about how you
know miners are really pro cyclical
force for bitcoin uh so you know they
hold their assets in the bull market and
then as you know you kind of see that
that turn around uh and all the dynamics
that we just described you know hash
continuing to come online while price is
coming down and then you throw on now
the the rising energy costs uh those
margins really come under pressure and
the inefficient miners that don't have
access to the cheapest energy uh they
have to at a minimum you know unplug
their machines at a worst case liquidate
their operations uh and so i do think
you've seen a lot of that and um you
know as long as bitcoin's price hangs
out down here and if it does go lower
then you'll see uh continued uh pressure
on on some of those miners and i do
think you'll see some consolidation of
miners who perhaps got a bit too greedy
and and you know didn't manage risk as
well as others uh over the last two
years
i i think that uh uh as people wake up
to what's happening obviously in
hindsight it's very easy to to kind of
identify all of this stuff right and be
like hey this is why this is occurring
and right now uh it's super valuable to
people because because they're starting
to realize okay the price doesn't just
magically go up the price doesn't just
magically go down there's actual things
that are driving that price uh and once
they start to understand what's happened
they start to see how complex and
intertwined so much of this is
everything from the contagion to the
minor selling the price the difficulty
adjustment the cost of electric like
there's just so much of it that is uh
interrelated uh before we uh we let you
go where can we send people to find you
on the internet or or subscribe uh to
the blockwear newsletter
sure no thanks man uh i'm on twitter at
w clementi uh i i appreciate you having
me on i try to put on the dress shirt to
get on your level with the suit
um you know we got to do what we got to
do here in this bear market uh you can
check out the newsletter it's in my bio
at blackwater blackwaterintelligence.com
if you're interested in anything i said
you you own a suit and tie
uh i do i have one yeah i have one too
this is the only one i have and i i wear
it every day now until the bear works we
got to get the bear market over john
laughs all the time because he's like we
got to get this over because he's tired
of wearing the suit and tie already
where's john's suit
john is right here in a t-shirt
john's too smart to uh to have signed up
for the suit and ties he's going to say
will the patagonia makes you makes me
think you're joining wall street
man i went to um
i went to new york two weeks ago
and uh i went i went and met someone in
uh like the financial district i was
walking through
and uh i saw bill ackman walking around
by the way and i was trying to get him
to buy our internet ponzi but he wasn't
interested um
i i saw a bunch of i saw a bunch of the
guys walking around like you know the
j.p morgan building the blackrock
building and they were all wearing this
vest and it was after i bought it i was
like oh god like i'm really like a
finance bro now that i bought this thing
that's the that's the uniform if you
don't got the uniform on then uh they're
in violation
all right buddy sounds good we'll talk
soon we'll do it again next friday all
right thanks guys for having me later
take care that was a great conversation
with will and i really enjoyed it don't
forget that these episodes are brought
to you by ftx us you can go click on the
link in the description ftx sometimes
has cheaper fees as much as 85 cheaper
than their competitors on top of that
they also offer digital stock trading in
beta which allows you to go buy various
stocks in app that doesn't have any
transaction fees and there's no payment
for order flow as ftx us continues to
build out their offering i think that
they are going to become the preeminent
brand in crypto trading in the united
states go check them out by clicking on
the link in the description and let me
know what you think that's it for this
week i hope that you guys enjoy these
updates every single week and we'll be
back next saturday to give you more
information then